prise peu après l'agression cette photo
révèle toute la violence du geste
jeudi dernier patrice malavaux garde
pêche du doubs franco-suisse a été
violemment attaqué son agresseur est un
agriculteur il s'en serait pris
physiquement et verbalement à lui pour
avoir diffusé ces images datées de fin
décembre
on y voit des traces d'épandage de purin
sur sols enneigés
une pratique interdite quelques semaines
plus tard le même agriculteur récidiver
on a passé un palier dans l' escalade de
la bêtise et voilà il ya des gens qui
essaient de défendre le milieu naturel
et la ressource en eau puis en a
d'autres qui répondent par la violence
c'est inacceptable
les représentants de la filière agricole
ont réagi il condamne fermement ces
violences
il se fait déjà dit aura lieu et il fait
du tort à l'image de l'agriculture est à
l'image des agriculteurs qui ont plus
une aptitude d'être entrées dans un
dialogue par rapport aux enjeux
environnementaux et aux enjeux agricoles
que de régler les problèmes avec ses
besoins au delà de cet acte c'est la
question des risques sanitaires liés aux
épandages en période hivernale qui est
posée pour les pêcheurs et défenseurs de
l'environnement la pratique devrait être
totalement interdite
il faut attendre que la végétation elle
pompe qu'elle se remette en route elle
va pomper les excès d'azoté en phosphore
en nitrates et c'est qu'il ya dans ces
effluents mais quand on est au mois de
janvier la végétation est là en berne
elle pompe rien du tout donc tout ce
qu'on va mettre sur les terrains et vous
avez vu la semaine dernière avec les
crus du doubs et c est bien ça va direct
dans les rivières
à la suite de l'agression la victime et
le préfet du doubs en déposer plainte
une enquête est en cours